christian wansdorf professor für
kriminalistik ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet
geplante amoklauf an einer essener
schule dann dieser armbruch schütze
jetzt in bremerhaven wie ist die
situation an unseren schulen in
deutschland muss man sich sorgen machen
wie sicher sind die schulen
eine ganz klare botschaft wir müssen
keine angst haben die schulen sind nicht
unsicher statistisch betrachtet aus
kriminalistischer sicht ist das ein
phänomen was ein verschwindend geringes
maß auftritt gleichwohl ist natürlich
das versicherungs potenzial sehr groß
wir können nach jedem vorfall dabei
diesen vorfällen immer etwas
herausziehen was ins kriminal präventiv
also vorbeugend eben weiter bringt das
heißt aufmerksam sein und sorgsam sein
dass wichtig angst haben ist nicht
angebracht ein amoklauf der kann auch
dann immer weiter nachahmer auf den plan
rufen ist es so ist es so dass diese
aufmerksamkeit andere dann fast schon
man muss sagen inspiriert
leider ist das so wir sprechen hier in
einer etwas verharmlose in form von
sogenannten trittbrettfahrern ich würde
das hier gar nicht an werden diesen
begriff direkt ich gehe davon aus dass
für menschen die ohnehin eine neigung
eine idee in dieser richtung hatten dass
eine art initialzündung sein kann von
taten zu erfahren bei sehr spektakulären
suiziden vermeiden wir das in die
öffentlichkeit zu bringen eben um genau
diese nachahmung zu vermeiden hier bei
diesen vorteilen an schulen ist das
nicht möglich oder es kann durchaus ein
nachahmer effekt nach sich ziehen ja vor
allem die lehrer an den schulen müssen
besonders aufmerksam sein gibt es denn
irgendwelche warnsignale alarmsignale
auf die man unbedingt achten sollte gibt
es irgendwelche anzeichen für amokläufer
was muss man achten
also gerade den usa gibt es schon seit
vielen jahrzehnten forschung zu diesem
thema die sehr fundiert ist es gibt dort
wissenschaftler die sagen es gibt keine
amoktat den ich in irgendeiner weise
angekündigt ist sich selbst ankündigt
das sogenannte leaking so wird das
bezeichnet und dann ist natürlich die
frage die sich anschließt wie kann man
dann richtig reagieren also was ist dann
ein anzeichen für eine möglicherweise
bevorstehende am okt hat sie haben jetzt
gerade angesprochen lehrer schulpersonal
ist sicherlich wichtig aber in erster
linie sind es die familie die achtsam
sein können und die bestimmte
verhaltensänderung beispielsweise den
rückzug aus dem sozialen leben
verhaltensänderung
persönlichkeitsstruktur veränderungen im
wahrnehmen können und dann zu einem
vorzeitigen zeitpunkt etablieren können
kriminalist vielen herzlichen dank für
ihre analyse